i'll squeeze in
my jurassic park three questions so i
get it in
because probably no surprise here
i truly do have a great appreciation for
every single installment of that
franchise but there's one thing that
stands out that people love to share on
social media as a meme now
and i'm wondering your take on it the
very first time you read the scene in
jurassic park 3 when alan has the dream
and wakes up and
the raptor says his name what was your
first impression when you read that
oh that's pretty cool yeah that's it and
um yeah i
i i was just talking to someone earlier
in the day who
who said i do i really like jurassic
park three
and it gets it gets um it gets an unfair
tr i think he was from rotten tomatoes
i think it was him and i said thank you
very much
um i agree that the last the last 10
minutes of
way too easy and and way too hard but i
think
up to that point it's pretty damn good
uh but more than that for me i'd
um by the time i got to number three
probably a bit late in the day
i'd sort of worked out how to play that
character
and um which i hadn't really
quite gotten around to in in in in
in the first one and we're still trying
to work out
uh what how how do you play that guy
uh in the hat something that comes
completely naturally to someone like
harrison ford naturally to me
and something that chris pratt the
fantastic guy
has given a lot of thought to and really
worked out how to do it
and you have to think out how to do that
it's a special skill
it's not um it you're not just playing a
character
you you need to apply a whole bunch of
you you need a whole skill set you need
a whole armory
to play an action hero and um
and i wish i'd known what
those skills were when we when we did
the first one but there we are
you're so self-deprecating and all i all
i see
is is confidence in basically everything
that you're describing right now in alan
grant in the first movie
well that's good i got away with it then
you most certainly did here here's a
weird thor
ragnarok question for you because this
has been a very hot topic of
conversation among the collider
staff and it's a it's a little offbeat
i'm warning you
okay are you matt damon and luke
and luke hemsworth are you playing as
guardian actors
or did loki kidnap the real sam neil and
he's forced
i can't take credit for that it's
something swirling around social media
but we've been having fun with the idea
that's hilarious
but look i mean when when i went to see
the film
because i'm not really entirely you know
nerdistantly you know rusted onto the
marvel
to the marvel franchise i was completely
baffled by so many things okay
you know i went with friends who sort of
knew a bit more than me
do you know what planet we're on at the
moment and
is is is that is that hopkins or or
is it i was that like i i
and they were explaining it they said
you're in the film why do we have to
explain it to you i think
i i just i'm i'm a bit lost
i'm truly lost here
but um no i shouldn't really confess to
that i should really know what's going
on but it's
it is it it is a strange
it is it's it's not actually
it's that it looks like tony hopkins but
it's not